Speaking of which, there is a Christian
televangelist, pastor, scam artist really
named Kenneth Copeland. We've spoken about him
before. He is a really successful scammer. I've
mentioned before that the same cult like behavior
we see in Donald Trump's followers is what we see
in the followers of other cultists. And some
of these Christian televangelists and folks
like Kenneth Copeland are really great examples
of that. And Copeland, previously, during the
pandemic, finished the virus live on television,
commanding God to destroy it. He also claimed to
heal viewers through the television and generally
has scammed his disproportionately elderly
followers in really immoral ways. And he makes a
ton of money doing it. The grift reportedly has
given Kenneth Copeland a networth of 300 million
dollars. Well, the new one is that since Donald
Trump has recovered from Corona virus, not only
is Trump now immune, but Christians are all now
immune from the virus. Take a look at this clip.
I was noticing today
President Trump is beautiful. Firstly, without
masks, they are immune, right? They are immune.
And this display.
Of our president giving God thanks.
And for for a helping him in that that time
he walked out a view. That's right. Somehow.
Glory to God. Thank you, T.J.. Oh, hey,
come on, man. Some wear. Hey, we're we're
immune. That's right. That's right. We're going
through this thing with a Holy Spirit, immunity
from the works of the devil, you know?
I don't believe in demons, but seeing video
of Kenneth Copeland makes me think maybe they
do exist. I have to tell you, it's causing me
to doubt some of my beliefs in a sane world. He
would have no followers in a sane world. There
wouldn't be 300 million dollars in what he is
doing. We could simply laugh it off and say,
let's move on to the next thing. This is a
funny thing to watch with my morning coffee.
But this guy has followers. And Trump has tens
of millions of followers. And we have a country
where you can become really rich by telling people
lies like this. We have a country where you can
become president by bamboozling your followers and
encouraging them to do risky things like just go
out there even though there's a global pandemic.
And if Kenneth Copeland's elderly Christian
followers believe they're immune because he says
it, maybe they go without a mask. Maybe they do.
Large gatherings endorse and do all the things
that they shouldn't be doing. And this is also odd
because cemeteries are filled with Christians who
died from Koven. Is the idea that the Christians
only became immune after Trump recovered?
Well, even that doesn't make sense, because
even after Trump's recovery from Kofod, Christians
continue to die of the virus. This is scary stuff.
And when I see video of Kenneth Copeland, I almost
start looking for holy water to douse myself with.
It's really Jim Jones. Even Kim Jong un sort of
territory. And one thing I've been thinking about,
I don't have an answer, but I want to hear from
you. Should some aspect of what kind of Copeland
is doing be illegal? Now, I'm not suggesting it
should be necessarily. I'm not suggesting limiting
speech. I'm not suggesting we violate the First
Amendment. But is there some basis on which some
aspect of what Kenneth Copeland is doing should
be against the law? Let me know what you think.
I want to hear from you on the basis of it would
be the potential and actual harm that it creates.
There are many who say, hey, listen, buyer
beware. And if you want to buy what he's
selling by sending in money or whatever, that's
really up to the individual. So that's that's
my question that I leave you with. Should
some aspect of this be against the law?